[Music]
jeep purple are back four years after
their last album now what the heavy
metal and hard rock pioneers are
releasing a new one infinite the band
aimed to record it quickly and have it
sound like a live gig
[Music]
we've always been a kind of live band a
recording side of our careers the
secondary it's alive so bringing that
into the studio it was a very wise
decision and that's why I think it sound
so fresh we don't do for hardly ever
more than one or two maybe even three
takes and that's it the key to that of
course is that you have to be able to
play a critical point ladies and
gentlemen let's make a rock record right
everybody there infinite was recorded in
Nashville Tennessee
[Music]
[Applause]
that's where deep purple made their
previous album to this time around it
took the band less than a month to
develop rehearse and record infinite's
ten tracks when it comes to music
facilities Nashville is hard to beat
[Music]
they still have great big studios and if
you want to capture a live ish sound you
need a biggish room at this room it's
alive you know and I know when I hit
this drum is gonna go bang it's not
going to go put when the room is great
the atmosphere in the studio is great
everybody enjoys playing because they
know immediately the sound is there all
you have to do is capture it
[Music]
almost everyone knows that riff and
pretty much every guitarist can play it
smoke on the water is deep purple
signature song
[Music]
but its legacy is more than that track
in the early 1970s deep purple helped
bring heavy metal into the mainstream
and released groundbreaking albums year
after year 72 we did two albums six
tours of America on a tour of Japan I
mean in one year I can't imagine that
right yawns now at that time if a band
managed to stay together for four or
five years that was quite a long time
and manages being what they are this
rather fat goose laying the gold eggs
was not allowed to have a rest over it's
close to 50 year history the band's
lineup has changed considerably
guitarist steve morse has been with deep
purple since 1994
[Applause]
and keyboardist Don Airey joined in 2002
replacing the legendary John Lord he
published hands like deep purple not
because it's a style we've adopted it's
because we're actually a very natural
band we play in a very natural way and
whatever our natural talents are that's
that's the sound has to blend of those
talents it's changed because people have
changed but the instruments the same
still the Hammond on the guitar either
side that's an integral part of the bad
luck
[Music]
starting in May deep purple will take to
the road again on their long goodbye
tour that sounds rather final the tour
has no set and date how long is a piece
of string that's how long the tourists
we don't know it's it's we're just
putting everyone on notice that there we
are of an age and we will stop at some
point we just don't know when no but if
this is going to be the last major tour
then we want to go everywhere we can
play to everybody who wants to see it
and that could take a long time
[Music]
so hard rock and heavy metal fans
shouldn't miss the opportunity to catch
deep purple in action this time around
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you